The second case is simliar to the common case,
but the memory pressure on P is exacerbated in
this case. In this case, there's so much memory
pressure that all of the physical memory that's available at
P is being consumed by the working set, while
hosting all the applications running on host P. There's
no community service happening on host P. And now,
if there is another page fault, for some new page
on P, then there is no other option on
host P except to throw out some page from its
current working set in order to make room for
this missing page. So, we're going to do exactly similar
to what we did in the previous case, with
the only difference that the candidate that is being chosen
as a victim, or the replacement candidate, which is
called a victim, in the management of virtual memory system,
is coming from the local part of host P itself. So we get the missing page
and we send out the oldest page from
local part of host P, recognizing that the local
part is zero right now. So in this case you can see that there is no change
in the distribution of local and global on
P, because global is already zero, it's not going
to be anything less than that. So the
distribution remains unchanged. And as in the previous case,
there's no change on host Q as well
in terms of the split between local and global.